can we just go back to that perfect
moment you know start over
are you sure nothing's going on with you
i'm rahim
it's going to take a lot to top this
this is an incredible project and
has really changed my life in so many
ways like
i i'm just so grateful for it it's great
to see you coming to an end what has
been the best part of a series like love
victor as an actor it's like it's hard
to book an acting job and then when you
book one as special as this that really
makes an impact and connects with people
and you know i've been hearing so much
from like lgbtq youth who you know they
feel seen and they they love the show
and they really connect to it it's
really beautiful i want to be up front
and let you know i'm seeing someone
poured
actually wow that's so great i'm
actually dating someone too wow okay who
who's who's the lucky guy
it's lucy i'm dating lucy
surprise we always knew i think that
like the show was special but i don't
think we understood the scale like how
many people really were going to be
impacted i've seen a lot of people say
that they wish that they had this when
they were like a kid
and
how much the show has changed them what
do you think that fans of this series
are going to be in for with the third
and final season the one thing i mean i
really want them to be in for is uh
closure and like a wrap-up of these
characters that they've been following
for like the last three years and i
think we delivered that and i mean also
drama and comedy and everything in
between